I really enjoyed watching you live
before your game on game day and you
said something that was super
interesting you said shadura doesn't get
the respect he deserves because he's my
son can you just elaborate more on what
you mean by that yeah even coming out if
they would have just looked at him
coming out of high school as a
quarterback and he wasn't attached to me
he probably would have been the five
stars not that stars matter it matters
to kids it don't matter it's coaches and
if they would have looked at him just by
his ability and disconnect him from me
when even when he's at Jackson he was
like oh my God this kid mechanics are
unbelievable his his completion
percentage I mean his touchdown
interception ratio is crazy I mean he's
thrown 70 touchdowns in the last there
in two years and he started every game
of his college girl they don't look at
that that's his son he's giving him a
pass he's giving him that he's giving
him the job at at Colorado he's doing
this and not just understanding who he
is now that he's on the main stage
oh my gosh your door is this and
everything we've been told you that
right and it's upsetting to us it is
upsetting to him because he he you
shouldn't give him that chip now he has
that chip on his shoulder and uh that
Brady asked he's gonna find something to
get mad at every game and uh he has that
chip on his shoulder so then as a dad
before at this point what was it like
for you to maybe feel somewhat
responsible for the perception of him
[Music]
we ride in that together
because even when he chose to he was
going to FAU and the only reason he was
going after you was coach staggart and
that staff as well as
he wanted to start right away
he ain't going to sit on no bench he
said yeah how am I going to get better
sitting on the bench and I told him that
you don't get better sitting on the
bench
so he wanted to start right away because
he could have went to any any place
Alabama any place he desired to go but
he wanted to start right away so just
having him ride with me and we having
that conversation finally around the
house one day he said hey looking though
we're going to talk about this we just
gonna play like it ain't now I said
let's talk about it because I never
wanted to say hey you going with me so I
wanted him to make that decision he said
we're going to do this or not I said
cool he's gonna cost you a car though
so you're gonna hit your daddy up so
you're gonna hit your own dad up
yeah
I know I you know I saw that clip of you
talking with your sons there was a joke
about okay what if what if she do her
leaves yeah
we don't want to talk about that
[Music]
you got to understand now you know that
we never cut off guard or anything
[Music]
Daddy has been around the block a couple
times so we've discussed every possible
scenario that can be had with both of my
sons well all three of my sons because
Junior you know he's he's going to be up
there photographing it and doing his
thing with it
so we we've talked about everything it's
no surprises Under the Sun with us
so I guess I'm curious for you what do
you have to see
they are ready to make that jump it's
it's not about what I'm seeing from them
it's about
a whole lot of other things
um teams position
um round projection all of that plays a
role because now with nil and who they
are
shoot you could make just as much money
here
as you get in there unless you uh
you know one of the first five picks but
shadowy don't want to be too to nobody
he don't get down like that so you know
people projecting him behind uh you know
Kayla Williams and Caleb Williams is is
phenomenal but Shadow ain't no backseat
writer he ain't he you know he he drive
his Maybach he don't have a drive-in he
drives it the moment you knew he was
really good seven
what did you see it seven as well as
Shiloh because hit in my phone he's up
on the ground like grown he's a grown
man he's very mature for his age he's
always been calm cool and collected he
was checking off at seven years old and
Daddy was over there calling the place
for him and grooming him and I taught
him all defenses first so he knew it was
covered too you know especially in in
Youth League they ain't playing but
cover three cover two and he was
checking off getting the ball down the
field like in no time that's why we
didn't Flinch last week that's why up
two yard line 98 yards cool minute 40
minute whatever it was on the clock cool
he's done that before we got that he
don't Flinch and he loves that that
those moments he loves those moments
what was funny was his brother came to
me
Shadows say in overtime you know and he
rarely ever calls me dad on the field he
don't play that he's like Dad
you putting the defense out there first
I said y'all ain't stopped nobody all
day your brother going out there and I
know what he gonna do I mean that was
the attitude that really happened that
really happened I know what he gonna do
because I like to put pressure on people
I don't like people putting the pressure
on us I know he's going to apply instant
pressure and he did